tout savoir sur l'entrepreneuriat la
Chambre de commerce et d'industrie
Versailles linorganise son après-midi de
la création d'entreprises ça se passe
demain de 13h30 à 18h30 dans les locaux
de la CCI à Versailles avenue de Paris
et cet organisant partenariat avec
Banque Populaire val-de-france BP Crédit
Agricole Île-de-France Matmut et Pôle
emploi Versailles je le disais on en
parle avec vous Frédéric Dassonville
vous êtes le responsable du pôle
création est formalité d'entreprise à la
CCI Versailles première question
pourquoi organiser cet après-midi de la
création d'entreprise quelles sont les
objectifs alors les objectifs en fait
c'est de pouvoir expliquer à toute
personne qui s'intéresse à la création
dans d'entreprises de pouvoir lui
expliquer quels sont les différents les
parcours qui sont à réaliser pardon et
les différentes étapes essentielles pour
réussir son projet et ça leur permettra
aussi de rencontrer tous les acteurs qui
leur permettront vraiment de pouvoir
avancer sur leur projet et de
concrétiser leurs rêves entrepreneurial
en fait c'est difficile quand on est
employé ou même demandeur d'emploi de se
dans un statut de créateur d'entreprise
sera d'ailleurs je pense je crois à l'un
des l'un des ateliers demain mais c'est
difficile de faire cette transition
c'est difficile en fait il y a tout un
tout un état d'esprit qu'il faut qu'il
faut faire évoluer et évoluer lorsque
l'on est salarié bon voilà on a
l'entreprise qui qui qui peut porter les
salariés sur un certain nombre de sujets
alors que là on est son propre moteur
pour pouvoir avancer sur le projet et
faire en sorte qu'il soit rentable et le
faire vivre tout simplement à qui
s'adresse cet après-midi du coup c'est à
tous ceux qui souhaitent porter un
projet d'entreprise absolument c'est à
partir du moment où on est même un
simple porteur d'idées c'est à dire que
l'on réfléchit à un projet de création
d'entreprise on peut déjà venir à cet
après-midi de la création pour sa
culture et pour pour voir comment est-ce
qu'on peut avancer dans dans son projet
donc on soit un simple porteur d'idées
ou déjà bien avancé dans son projet on
peut tout à fait participer à cet
après-midi
Nicolas vous aviez peut-être une
question un mot sur les domaines
aujourd'hui les domaines d'activité dans
lesquels les créateurs d'entreprises
s'engagent c'est souvent les mêmes
thématiques qui reviennent ou alors où
il y a quelque chose une est-ce qu'il y
a une rupture avec le covid peut-être
une rupture alors en fait on a quand
même sur les les les
créations d'entreprises environ 70%
d'activité de service qui sont créés
environ 20% de son disgridité des
activités de commerce c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui compte tenu des
problématiques d'inflation etc les
activités de commerce sont beaucoup plus
difficiles à déployer et effectivement
avec la crise covid voilà les achats sur
internet ont pris ont pris quand même le
le pli sur ça et donc c'est beaucoup
plus complexe à ce niveau là donc les
activités de service en plus en plus le
vent en coupe d'Iron vous parlez d'un
phénomène d'inflation on va rentrer un
peu dans la technique économique Grégory
mais on voit aussi les taux d'intérêt
augmenter alors il y a des difficultés
sur le marché de l'immobilier puisque
ceux qui veulent acheter un bien
immobilier du mal à accéder au crédits
qu'en est-il concernant les chefs
d'entreprise qui n'ont pas forcément de
fonds propres pour engager une création
d'entreprise est-ce que les banques
aujourd'hui font confiance aux créateurs
d'entreprises les banques font toujours
confiance aux porteurs de porteurs de
projets effectivement les taux ont aussi
augmenté un tout petit peu mais il
existe en fait des dispositifs qu'on
appelle des frais d'honneur qui sont des
prêts à taux zéro et sans garantie qui
permettent en fait au porteurs de projet
d'accroître son son apport en tout cas
de compléter son apport personnel et
donc de faciliter la levée de dettes
bancaire et donc demain nous aurons la
présence d'un certain nombre de ces
associations pour ben voilà faciliter
encore une fois le lancement des projets
et justement qui pourront-ils rencontrer
sur place pour cet après-midi de la
création d'entreprise pour rencontrer
alors on a pas mal de pas mal
d'opérateurs puisqu'on a justement ces
structures ces associations qui font du
financement de prêt d'honneur on a par
exemple le Réseau Entreprendre le réseau
initiative qui qui sera là nous avons
nos partenaires bancaires que vous avez
cité tout à l'heure nous avons des
avocats des experts comptables on a
évidemment le Pôle emploi qui est un qui
est un opérateur important pour
favoriser la création d'entreprise nous
avons aussi des structures comme comme
BP et des entreprises pardon et des
associations d'accompagnement qui elles
les porteurs de projets à monter les
business plan et à
aller chercher de l'argent en fait voilà
pour revenir sur le sujet que j'évoquais
vous êtes pas inquiet par rapport à ce
qui se passe aujourd'hui inflation un
ralentissement peut-être de l'économie
mais bon ok on peut on peut toujours
être inquiet mais il faut il faut être
positif dans le monde de la de la
création d'entreprise et effectivement
on peut on peut se poser un certain
nombre de questions liées au coût
d'achat des matières des matières
premières qui augmentent vraiment le
coût de l'énergie aussi qui est
important mais on essaie quand même de
trouver des solutions pour que les
structures puissent se monter et même si
on a un tout petit peu d'inquiétude on
essaie vraiment de pousser les gens vers
la création et là où je veux aller aussi
c'est on a eu des chiffres quand même
record avec la création d'entreprise en
2022 suite au covid il y a eu un
phénomène aussi de rattrapage par
rapport au covid aujourd'hui est-ce que
c'est chiffre records se confirment
va-t-on vers de nouveaux records ou
finalement il y a un ralentissement de
la création
sont plutôt ouvert en tout cas la
situation est plutôt bonne oui de
création d'entreprise sur les Yvelines
on a eu 6500 créations créations sur le
sur le premier trimestre ce qui confirme
la tendance de 2022 où on était
effectivement sur une année record on
pourrait être sur
25026000 ou 27000 créations
d'entreprises à la à la fin de l'année
donc la tendance est bonne mais c'est
vrai qu'il y a beaucoup de création
d'entreprises et de micro-entreprises
qui représentent quand même le corpus le
plus important sur les créations donc
voilà donc oui moi je pense qu'il y a il
y a quand même un vrai engouement pour
l'entrepreneuriat et aujourd'hui les les
personnes sont très intéressées par tout
ça donc a priori Chris covid et très
dernièrement la crise en l'Ukraine qui a
on l'a dit a pu agir sur l'augmentation
des décharges ça freine pas les les
porteurs de projets je pense qu'ils
essaient de préparer beaucoup plus
précisément leurs projets ça veut pas
dire qu'avant c'était pas le cas bien
évidemment mais voilà maintenant les
dispositifs d'accompagnement permettent
aux porteurs de projet d'intégrer
vraiment c'est dimension de difficultés
financières et donc du coup il y a pas
il y a pas de frein vraiment lié à ce
contexte économique et international
comment justement la CCI dans ce
contexte un peu contraint
accompagne-t-elle les porteurs de
projets comment comment se matérialise
on va dire cet accompagnement alors nous
avons des dispositifs d'accompagnement
collectif à travers des formations
notamment le 5 jours pour entreprendre
ou le dispositif qui s'appelle start
entrepreneur donc ils sont des
dispositifs collectifs et on a également
des accompagnements individuels à
travers des dispositifs qui sont
cofinancés par la Région
Île-de-France et également par l'Europe
qui s'appelle entrepreneur leader dans
lequel le bénéficiaire peut
avoir environ 10 une bonne dizaine
d'heures d'accompagnement individuels
pour monter son business plan valider
son modèle économique et donc aller
demander des financements et valider son
projet donc pour valider son projet
d'entreprise alors demain on le précise
il y aura différents ateliers on a
commencé à les évoquer il y aura
notamment un atelier sur les grandes
étapes les étapes clés pour créer son
entreprise très concrètement quelles
sont les quels sont-elles ces grandes
étapes on en saura un peu plus demain
l'entreprise alors en fait les grandes
étapes de l'entreprise c'est validé déjà
ce qu'on appelle l'adéquation homme
projet ensuite réaliser une étude de
marché pour être sûr qu'il y a un vrai
besoin et un vrai marché ensuite
travailler sur la partie juridique de
l'entreprise et enfin transformer tous
ces aspects là en chiffres et donc
préparer un business plan financier qui
permettra voilà de définir quelle est la
rentabilité du projet et on arrive
malheureusement à la fin de cet
entretien pour en savoir plus
rendez-vous demain à la CCI Versailles
avoir toutes les informations s'afficher
pour cet après-midi de la création
d'entreprises donc 13h30 18h30 l'adresse
des locaux de la CCI 21 23 avenue de
Paris il faut esquisse faut s'inscrire
avant de avant de venir les inscriptions
sont clauses depuis la fin de depuis la
fin de matinée mais néanmoins vous
pouvez tout à fait venir même si vous
n'êtes pas inscrit donc voilà vous
arrivez et puis on vous orientera il y a
pas de souci donc c'est gratuit oui oui
c'est totalement gratuit c'est
totalement gratuit donc vous pouvez
venir demain même si vous n'êtes pas
inscrit il y a aucun problème on vous
accueille avec grand plaisir merci
Frédéric Dassonville d'être venu en
parler en plateau responsable du pôle
création et formalités d'entreprise à la
CCI Versailles